- [Narrator] In this video
I want to start to answer
the question of how did
the environment and how did
political factor impact trade?
And that is a really big
question that we're not
gonna answer in one video,
but I want to use a specific
example to illustrate
the role of environment
and the role of politics in shaping trade.
So I want to start in
Birka, which is roughly here
in present day Sweden.
And the reason I start
here is that in the late
1800s a team of archeologists
working in this site
uncovered a woman's
grave, among other things,
and found in that grave
the ring that we see
in the photo here.
And they've dated this
grave and the ring they
found in it to somewhere
in the 9th century.
So somewhere in between
the years 800 and 900 or so
and we can see in our bigger
timeline that that falls
right into what's called the viking age
and the vikings were people
living in Scandinavia
and this region shaded in red.
They weren't a single political entity,
there were a lot of smaller
more independent communities,
but they shared a lot of
cultural characteristics.
So back to our ring,
firstly it's made of silver.
Secondly, the bead that's
set into it is made of
a really high quality glass.
And that's of a higher
quality that archeologists
have found in Scandinavia
from this time period.
So those two facts would
indicate that the ring is
probably from somewhere else.
There's an inscription on the ring,
it's kind of hard to see,
but if you look closely
you can sort of make it
out and linguists and
archeologists who have
looked at this are fairly
certain that this is a
form of old Arabic script.
And they think it says
something along the lines
of to or for Allah.
And I mentioned that the
vikings shared a lot of
cultural characteristics and
one of those characteristics
was that they all spoke Norse languages.
So an Arabic inscription
on the ring implies really
strongly that the ring did
not come from Scandinavia.
So that should raise the
question for you of where
did this ring come from and
how did it end up in Birka?
So the first factor we can
look at to try and figure
out where this ring came
from and how it got here
is to look at the political context.
The political context at any given time
is gonna determine where
and what goods are traded.
So think about it like this,
if there are two groups
of people and they have a
relatively good political
relationship it's more
likely that they're gonna
trade with each other, too.
So if we look at the political
situation, broadly speaking,
during the viking age we
have three major empires.
The first in purple we
have the Byzantine Empire,
which was what was left of
the Roman empire at this time.
We have, in yellow, the Abbasid Caliphate,
and this is the Islamic
empire that was founded
in about 750.
And then we have, in blue,
the Carolingian empire
in Europe, and that's
named after Charlemagne who
in Latin is Carolis Magnus,
so Carolingian comes
from that.
And I should point out on
the timeline the Carolingian
empire does continue
after Charlemagne's death,
it just becomes a little bit
more fractured politically.
Empires tend to have large cities,
they can support larger
concentrations of people,
which means larger
concentrations of wealth,
which in turn means that
there is more demand.
So cities become attractive
to traders because you
have a lot of customers in
one spot and those imperial
cities, especially, tend to
concentrate a lot of wealth
if they are the seat of government too.
So I'm gonna pull our cities onto the map,
and as we look around here
we can see Aachen is the
capital of the Carolingian
empire, which is actually
geographically quite close to the vikings.
We have Constantinople
as the Byzantine capital,
and then we have Baghdad
which is the Abbasid capital
down here.
And when we look at those
three empires and those three
cities specifically,
only one of them speaks
Arabic and writes Arabic.
And that would be the Abbasid Caliphate.
So that would mean that
the most likely place of
origin for this ring was
somewhere in the Abbasid
Caliphate in yellow down here.
So we want to think about
why would the vikings be
trading with the empire that's
farthest away from them?
Well, part of the answer is political.
So if we look at the
relationship between the vikings
and the Carolingians, for
example, one of Charlemagne's
big projects as the ruler
of the Carolingian empire
was to wage war against and
try to convert the Pagans
who were living on the
northeastern edge of his empire.
So there's this ongoing
conflict between Charlemagne
and non-Christians, including the vikings,
and that tends to hurt the
potential economic relationships
that they could have.
And you actually see the
vikings raid the coast of the
Carolingian empire in the
ninth century, as well.
So the vikings are trading
with the Byzantines
and with the Abbasids,
what they're engaging in is
what we call long distance trade.
So when we talk about long distance trade,
what we usually see are luxury goods.
And luxury goods are goods
that are rare and expensive.
And so in all of these
empires what we see is
the political context, the
fact that they have large
powerful empires, makes it
likely that they have more
advanced technology which
means that they're able to
produce higher quality, more
technologically advanced,
goods.
But then we have to ask what
do the vikings have that
they would be trading with
these more advanced empires?
Well one thing we can point
out here is that the vikings
in Scandinavia are in a
very different climate
than we have down in the Byzantine empire,
in the Abbasid Caliphate,
and to a certain extent,
different than even what
the Carolingians have,
although we pointed out
some of the political issues
prevented more trade from
occurring between them.
And the point we could make
about the different climates
is that climates determine
what resources are available.
So if we look at what
the vikings are trading,
we see things that are somewhat
unique to their climate.
And when we talk about the viking traders,
a lot of what they're doing
is actually coming across
the Baltic Sea into this
region here, the Baltic region,
we call that and they are
obtaining goods such as timber.
And specifically the timber
they want are from pine trees.
And pines in the Baltic tend
to grow very tall and straight
and that makes them really
attractive for building material.
Also, it's much colder in
this climate and animals,
fur-bearing mammals,
especially will tend to grow
nicer thicker coats if
they live in cold climates
and that makes them more
attractive then as potential
clothing items.
Another resource we see
frequently in the Baltic region
is amber, and that is dried tree resin.
And that can be polished
and shaped into stones for
jewelry, for decoration, as well.
And the vikings also do
engage in the slave trade.
They'll kidnap and take people
from this region and then
trade them as slaves with
these imperial capitals,
that is not something that's
necessarily influenced by
the environment, but it is
also a part of this trade.
Some of the most popular
items that the vikings are
trading for are things like
fabrics, especially silk,
which is produced in these empires.
I also mentioned glass earlier.
We saw the glass inset in the ring,
they also are making glass
vessels like drinking glasses.
You can see a picture of one here.
And that is gonna be of a
much better quality than
anything that the vikings
are able to produce.
So that glass becomes an
attractive technology.
There's a lot of silver
coming out of, especially,
the Abbasid Caliphate.
One of the reasons that
they know this trade was
occurring more broadly is
that in the Baltic region
and along some of the travel
routes between the Baltic
and the Abbasid Caliphate
archeologists have found
hordes, or large collections,
of silver Abbasid coins.
And so we see here both silver and glass,
the elements of that
ring that we discovered,
are things that are being
traded for by the vikings
coming from this region.
So we see the climate
impacting to a certain extent
what goods exist in different regions.
So there's an environmental impact there.
We also see geography or
environment affecting the
transportation of goods.
So what I want to do next
is pull in the commonly
used trade routes at this time.
And this helps us to
understand how these goods
actually move between these places.
So we see that the major
trade routes between the
Baltic region and the
Byzantines and the Abbasids
follow major river systems.
And the vikings are able
to take advantage of these
river systems in part
because of the technology
that they possess.
So again we see the environment
playing a role in trade
and determining what
routes are convenient to
transport goods.
And one other point I would
make about these routes
that develop is we see
these cities of Novgorod,
of Kiev, and of Bulgar that
pop along these trade routes
and these cities sort of
grow because the trade
routes exist.
These cities themselves become
center of trade over time.
So to come back to our
ring that we started the
video with, hopefully
this is looking less like
an anomaly, a strange find,
and more like the natural
result of the existing
trade networks that were
in in place because of the
environmental and because
of the political conditions at this time.